last night we exposed the lies and the
fear-mongering used to justify closing
schools across America we showed the
best science out there on why all
schools all schools should reopen to
their students preferably five days a
week the response I have to say was huge
and it was bipartisan children must be
taught in person nevertheless Louisville
Kentucky just announced that all fall
classes will be online same with San
Francisco schools now forget that
extensive new German study showing that
kids can't readily spread the virus or
that schools across Europe have not seen
any major spreads those schools have
been open can't let the facts get in the
way of spreading panic as far as the
media's hyperventilation about rising
Hospital numbers remember this is
chiefly tied to what's happening in four
states Florida California Texas and
Arizona where numbers did increase after
a perfect storm of reopening protests
riots and travel from south of the
border now by the way even in Arizona
the rolling number of confirmed cases is
already lower compared to one week ago
that's good news we hope it continues
but now we talk about the issue of masks
mandates we've seen what can happen when
people come together with face coverings
we want to give people more confidence
to shop safely and enhance protections
for those who work in shops both of
these can be done by the use of face
coverings you could literally kill
someone because you didn't want to wear
a mask I'm convinced that the benefit of
wearing a mask clearly is there now I
want to make clear I'm not telling
anyone not to wear a mask
that's not what we're here for instead I
want to move beyond hyperbole and focus
on what the latest science actually
tells us now we've heard for months that
wearing face coverings even homemade
ones cloth ones is a selfless thing to
do and it's even a patriotic duty which
I have to say sounds pretty cool and it
even sounds like a unifying thing the
emotional argument is
is really wonderful but again what about
the actual data now consider the
following from the very medical journals
and organizations that were led to
believe are infallible a 2015 study
recruited healthcare workers from
hospitals in Hanoi Vietnam and examined
the benefits of cloth mass used in a
healthcare setting and then measured flu
and flu-like virus transmission well the
results may surprise you the rates of
all infection outcomes were highest in
the cloth mask arm penetration of cloth
mass by particles was almost 97 percent
and medical masks 44 percent now this
was a randomized controlled trial of
more than 1,600 healthcare workers and
had this stunning conclusion the results
caution against the use of cloth masks
this is an important finding to inform
occupational health and safety moisture
retention reuse of cloth masks and poor
filtration may result in increased risk
of infection hmm okay well what about
the World Health Organization I'm sure
they recommend masks well just go to the
WHL website where they say there is
limited evidence than wearing a medical
mask by healthy individuals and
households in particular those who share
a house with a sick person or among
attendees of mass gatherings may be
beneficial as a measure of preventing
transmission at present there is no
direct evidence on the effectiveness of
universal masking of healthy people in
the community to prevent infection with
respiratory viruses including kovat 19
[Music]
hmm then there's the gold standard
itself the CDC now back in January it
recommended against masks and doctor
foul she repeated that guidance in March
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask when you're in the middle of
an outbreak wearing a mask might make
people feel a little bit better and it
might even block a droplet but it's not
providing the perfect protection that
people think that it is now she recently
explained his mask slip he's now in
favor of them saying those comments
initially were motivated by his concern
for saving masks for health care workers
Facebook by the way I found this out
today now flags the old interview with
pouchy as false information but he sure
seemed convincing but that's not all an
April study published in Nature seemed
consistent with the old foutch II as
well it measured and compared viral
shedding in the coughing of a hundred
and eleven participants some wearing
masks some not the results among the
samples collected without a face mask we
found that the majority of participants
with influenza virus and coronavirus
infection did not shed detectable virus
in respiratory droplets or aerosols for
those who did shed virus and respiratory
droplets and aerosols viral load in both
tended to be low weight what the
majority of confirmed coronavirus
infections without a face mask didn't
shed detectable virus and respiratory
droplets or aerosols and for those who
actually did the minority there was very
little virus present ok wait it gets
better
the major limitation of our study was
the large proportion of participants
with undetectable viral shedding and
exhaled breath for each of the viruses
studied we could have increased the
sampling duration beyond 30 minutes to
increase the viral shedding being
captured but apparently people didn't
want to do that so again let me just
explain this over the space of 3
minutes they were unable to capture any
viral shedding in a large proportion of
participants with confirmed known
infections again what indeed
they go on to explain that perhaps
forced coughing forced coughing might
have helped forced coughing so so the
issue as is explained in this study is
that non coughing or sneezing people are
by and large not shedding virus in their
ordinary breath if they're coughing well
of course that's a different story of
course someone who is actively sick is
well you know they're actively sick but
especially now many coronavirus
infections are not symptomatic for cough
and among those actively sick but not
coughing they had great difficulty in
this study finding virus expelled under
lab conditions and in lab conditions has
extremely sensitive equipment again
these are people who were actively sick
and had a fever so so so much for the
theory of asymptomatic shedding of
infectious virus out of one's mouth or
nose by the way the entire premise on
which the mask mandates are predicated
do you see or smell or hear a problem
here there's conflicting information
scientific findings on mask use and
masks on kids well it's hard to see how
any of that should be the new normal
given reported low levels of infective
'ti and infectiousness of children again
I'm not discouraging anyone from merit
wearing a mask but the world is full of
experts who got big issues wrong isn't
it before Americans are forced to accept
new restrictions on their freedoms or
even be shamed or even beaten up for not
complying with these mandates shouldn't
state legislators hold hearings and
discuss the findings that I just brought
you tonight then they should pass actual
laws about masks so social distancing
all of it that can withstand judicial
scrutiny
we must insist on all of this demand to
see all of the science behind the
lockdown social distancing and the masks
otherwise don't be surprised if you lose
your pre kovat way of life for the rest
of your life and that's the angle